so uh next up we have my uh colleague
and friend uh Glenn bursath Glenn is an
assistant professor at the University of
Montreal he's a Mila core member a
seatbar AI chair and he's co-director of
the Robotics and embodied AI lab and uh
he's going to talk about something that
is near and dear to my heart which is
robot learning or embodied AI take it
away Glenn
great yeah thank you very much Liam all
right
how's everyone doing this morning
excited for your last day you've learned
so much this week I'm hoping there's
still a little bit of space left for me
to try and put some more information
into your brain for this morning and
you've had some good carbs from the
bagels from this morning to help that
happen
okay so yeah today yeah I've got a
particular interest in you know seeing
what I need to do in order to get most
of the algorithms you've talked about
from this week to work on like real
applications real world hardware and if
there are changes in theory or basically
from a very depth perspective what needs
to be done or to make those things
really happen and where those
limitations are with current methods so
I'll be talking a lot about basically
those Concepts today and also you know
I'm a little bit more make this more of
a discussion please feel free to ask
questions during this at any time I left
room for at least 30 minutes of
questions I'm joking so there's plenty
of time but please feel free to ask
questions
so so I'll be talking a bit about today
really a lot about like what's needed to
get RL working
and I'm going to be going over what I've
kind of came up with yesterday is
thinking about this and kind of three
different aspects we really want to be
able to reuse stuff really well if you
train some model it's like the whole
Paradigm for computer vision this should
be a useful model that someone can use
later so how can we also embed this into
the way we're training agents with RL as
well using even just a version of goal
conditioning a way to recycle things
I'll talk about more what I mean by this
but we have a lot of data out there how
can we use it in even more applications
so we can have more access to them and
in many ways you know people often hear
that reinforcement learning is
incredibly data inefficient uh maybe I
can try and at least make you you know
convince you a little bit that's not
entirely true it might be other things
but not entirely data inefficient
and I'll talk about sort of these
reasons down here about why that might
be less true
okay
so let's talk about these different
three R's so you've got reduce we really
want to reduce the amount of data that's
going to be needed Maybe by using
different priors or you can use
different computer vision models but I'm
going to talk more about what's becoming
really useful these days which is
offline reinforcement learning as a good
way to be able to like reduce the extra
amount of data that every agent needs to
learn
and then the ReUse part I'll talk more
about specifically for goal conditioned
RL it's just a way to talk about this
concept like you train a model and now
you have some other conditioning
variable and hopefully you can use this
other places but what does this really
mean we'll go into some more of those
details and then this recycle part which
is something I've been particularly
interested in for the last two years is
quite literally how much can I recycle
data almost that was never meant to be
used for this particular thing but can I
still make some useful bits out of this
gather some of the useful bits of
information and reuse that
okay and then a little bit of a side I
do some other work in autonomous kind of
RL safe RL systems design
obviously things related to robotics but
I won't be discussing those today
there's just not enough time to cover my
entire class in one hour I'm going to do
as best as I can for maybe more of the
stuff that hasn't been covered in the
summer school already
and this is an example of some of my
kind of like more recent work where I
try to get like a system to train from
scratch that wasn't any pre-training at
all on this robot Hardware we just stuck
it in this room told it to start trying
to collect stuff collect data and
collect things and it learns how to
clean up your room over time entirely
trained from vision
no extra data no vision models needed
okay
so then how
do you change the page
Plus
all right
I guess I'll be a bit more careful
playing videos from now on okay so it's
a little bit about what's wrong with
this assumption when we're applying
reinforcement learning to the real world
we basically are doing this process
we've got some policy it's going to into
sorry introduce basically some
distribution of how the agent is going
to act in the world this can be
incredibly long and complicated over
time
and in the end we're always just trying
to maximize this reward objective for
reinforcement learning it's the thing
that you know as a roboticist I try to
tell my robot you know this is the thing
I want you to do this is the behavior I
want you to be able to come up with
please don't do anything else although
that tends to happen very often so we
want to maybe get better at this but
this talk is a little less about this
part
and more about denialing with these
other problems in reinforcement learning
or we might have to worry about you know
having really long tasks you know if
you've got something related to cooking
cooking is a pretty long task many
different steps many different things
you have to interact with and you need
to be able to learn a policy for this
whole thing and if we're just rolling
out individual policy distributions for
like 40 minutes and then trying to back
propagate all this information back into
the policy it's going to be incredibly
sample inefficient
and there's also this area for novel and
sparse rewards which I talked about for
a bit so in some ways I don't really
want to have to craft this reward
function in a very specific way I just
want to say okay go and solve The
World's problems I'm going to go to the
pool right now if you could do that
that'd be great instead because I like
swimming
so we really want to be able to push
forward on that part of the problem too
and I'll talk a little bit about that
so when we're talking about this part
you know like learning long tasks one of
the really helpful pieces is thinking
about the fact that there is a lot of
composition in the world and we really
want to find ways to take advantage of
this
so you can have one giant policy but
when you have really long Horizon tasks
it either causes credit assignment
problems and it makes just general
exploration and planning very difficult
so can we at least break up this problem
into smaller problems so like for
example cooking soup is a very
compositional problem how many people
like to cook
you know good time good break from work
definitely can't interact with your
computer while you're trying to cook
which is a good way to like a good
pastime
so then you should know a bit about like
cooking soup in this case you're gonna
end up Gathering a bunch of vegetables
so even now like just Gathering things
from the fridge or wherever is one task
you're gonna do repeatedly even if
you're going for different items
you go to cut some vegetables but you
can cut onions you can also cut carrots
a number of other things if you're more
familiar with like you know dicing
things julienning things there are even
classifications of way to chop things so
these are not in some sense very
different tasks even though you might be
interacting with a slightly different
object each time but there is a lot of
reuse in the overall policy structure
that the agent needs to you know use in
order to solve these tasks
so you instead though you could just
train like one policy for every single
one of these tasks you know train one
policy this is the cutting carrots
policy and a different policy for
cutting onions the problem is is you end
up with this giant set of policies
there's not very much reuse between all
these so instead you want to be able to
train these you know in a couple of
different ways so I've already talked a
little bit about why this is a bad thing
so basically we're not getting any of
this for use even though there's a lot
of similar structure so I'm going to
talk about all right how can we start to
take advantage and at least develop a
policy training structure that will take
you know take advantage of some of this
reuse some additional structure and
composition that's inside of these tasks
so maybe I'll just put this down since I
tend to be standing here the entire time
can everyone still hear me
good perfect thank you
okay so instead of having a set of
policies
let's just think of it this way simple
way all right now we've got one policy
let's just introduce a context and the
case where we're cutting vegetables this
could be the description of you know
something that says it's a carrot versus
an onion or something like that
otherwise most of your cutting is still
pretty much the same and you can reuse
that policy that you've learned
so in practice when we've been doing
this more in machine learning lately we
do this in a fairly simple way in just
this first example where you could think
of we're literally just gonna make like
a one hot Vector there's a bunch of
zeros in this there's a one that's going
to indicate this is the task you're
going to do
so basically when your policy has some
input and it's going to have some image
and then some input that's C and then
these are the things that are going to
go into your network now you've added
this additional context
and the idea is now this neural network
will encapsulate a lot of the other
similar shared information implicitly
inside of this network so this is good
now we don't have to train a bunch of
individual policies this will probably
also save us time and the things we need
to train
okay so then the real part that becomes
complex is what if we start to have
tasks that overlap so we could train a
bunch of these in different ways maybe
get a couple of them but you know it was
really easy when I just told you okay
we've got a different task for cutting
carrots versus cutting onions onions and
the vegetable is literally how you're
chopping up or sorry separating the
different tasks just trying not to use
the word cutting or any other kitchen
terms in the sentence so it's less
confusing so let's look at this
navigation example Instead This one
helps see some of the problems with this
composition
so if we're gonna you know start out at
zero here one two three four about five
you know in navigation you kind of want
to say like go to x go to this XY
location you know even somewhere inside
of this room
and if we were going to use this context
approach up here it means that basically
okay I need to have now a context for if
I were to chop this up and discretize it
into 100 different spaces my context is
now length 100 and it's not making very
good use of even like the bits of
information that you can use in this
context
so we want to know can we do better like
even inside of this space
so what if we actually you know separate
our context here so instead of having
you know one one hot Vector for 100
spaces you could technically you know
split this up into two different context
vectors one for going to x one for going
to Y and now you can train a policy
that'll hopefully understand how to
interpret or sorry interpolate the
different contexts they use now and now
you don't need to train your policy on
every one of the 100 contexts that were
in this before hopefully you can train
them on some sparse combination of these
different contexts for X and Y
now you'd be able to locate each other
in the room
does this make sense any questions so
far
pretty good
all right fantastic
so in this case
you can still do okay so this is already
helping we come up with a slightly
better representation you can still the
policy can learn that there is a kind of
like a cross product representation
between these two contexts to help you
represent where the true goal is
and that you can definitely get some
um
I guess interpolation there too so if
you just trained on like this location
this is your start
these are different goals ideally if you
specified a new goal in this location
now your policy can interpolate between
the x's and y's you use during training
so this is now we talked about this very
specific form of what is goal
conditioned reinforce the learning
so we'll get into this case now where
all right so what if our decomposable
structure is far less obvious you know
this is the real world
and in many ways I've had this
discussion with a few of my students and
people too is like dude tasks even exist
they do provide some useful structure
for at least relearning policies so if
we can use these it often means that the
there's that's such a clear separation
between one task and another task
and especially in this case where I'm
just gonna you know if we're making this
cooking robot you know it means in this
case there's a bunch of different types
of things and you know I'm also got my
own like bias in the background I'm used
to cooking well somewhat used to cooking
things that are somewhat from like the
Canadian Cuisine there's probably other
types of cooking that are going to have
more interesting and novel stuff that
I'd love to learn about and be able to
integrate those as well so it's going to
be not you know you can't make a perfect
controller and you want to be able to
add more of this diversity and extra
additional bits into it as well
so the real kind of next step in this
building on that is instead of having
just sort of this conditioning one hot
variable basically we're kind of now
moving from this discrete space now into
the continuous space where you've got a
goal and it's less clear in how to
represent what this goal is
so you can have goals of all sorts of
things you can still give locations but
instead of having this grid I'm going to
give you like the GPS location of where
to go inside of this room that could be
a goal description and there's a lot of
new work which I'll get into here where
it's more like you know I give you a
picture of somewhere inside of this room
and you have to figure out okay where is
this picture representing that location
and also how to go to there technically
two different problems one is this goal
representation problem of taking that
picture understanding what it actually
means it's really like what am I trying
to tell the robot to do which is a
different kind of separate problem for
inferring the reward and then trying to
train the policy to understand if I give
you this representation that's a picture
now you need to know what this goal is
and how to actually get to that goal
slight variation on the problem
so this is you know so if you were to
train you know some stuff where we
really want to get this generalization
between goals and if we're doing this in
the discrete space the theory is nice
but you don't always get as easy and
nice generalization and reuse
where you can just have like this
interpolation where if you train over a
bunch of separate goals where you
basically cover most of this grid then
you should have a policy thanks to a lot
of the features that basically come
along with deep networks the fact that
we have a parameterized model means that
we can hope with some good proper some
good properties that there should be
some interpolative Behavior between the
different goals that you could specify
if there isn't well you're definitely
paddling up the wrong river and you
should probably maybe make your network
smaller or you're going to need to
sample this goal space more and more
ideally we don't want to have to sample
this goal space a lot you know we want
to be able to have you know versions of
learning systems that are as smart as
people you've already all been in this
room a couple of times I'm sure if I
gave you just a few example goals I
probably don't even have to anymore you
can find your location in this room now
without having to need much more data
so that's sort of the uh that's the
ideal place we're trying to get to with
really good learning systems
so then when we get down to this one of
the additional benefits is you know
being able to train on this bar set and
there's a lot of algorithms basically
that are designed to figure out what are
the best set of goals to sample amongst
this space such that you get like this
much you know performance out of your
policy it's actually somewhat even
related to some of the robust RL
discussion from the last talk you know
how can you actually learn an mdp that's
going to cover your space well enough to
get this amount of performance
so this is you know helpful I'm not
going to talk as much about that in this
though
instead we're going to go back to this
okay we're going to do goal condition RL
and we really want to do it from images
because you know I don't want to have to
specify a particular goal space the
internet and world is full of images
they're nice and cheap and if I can just
give you this image then hopefully you
can just tell our robot please achieve
this
so we're going to switch a little bit
where for this goal conditioned RL from
images it's literally like all right I
want you to in this case set the table
here's an image of my table hopefully it
was you know like clean at one point in
my life and I can take an image of that
and now save that very carefully and I
can give that to my robot whenever I
want the robot to reconfigure the state
of my apartment to look like that one
again
however the problem now is when you're
getting into images is it was really
easy to determine what the context was
from before you know like if you end up
if you're the robot and you walk around
and you end up within the grid point
that I said you should go to Great you
get a reward of one that's pretty easy
to Define but now if I give you an image
or at least you know like a robot in
this case and say like please go and
make the world like this how is it going
to determine that it's successfully
achieved making the world look like this
it's a lot of the like more challenging
part but now we're basically going to
try we'll talk about being able to train
some image representations now where we
can now still compute distances inside
of images
so the part though that still becomes
tricky for being able to learn this is
now you basically instead of having a
context from before
so before in our policy distribution we
just had actions and observations now
you have a goal that we're going to give
the agent so this is additional input
that we're going to condition the policy
on and now we also have to worry about
the environment should be giving us some
distribution of goals like these are the
tasks that we want the agent to be able
to learn how to perform
and then our Dynamics will normally stay
the same but for this particular problem
let's just assume the goal stays the
same for the entire episode nothing too
complicated where we're going to change
this over time and then our Dynamics get
more confusing
even this is a hard enough problem to
talk about for today
so now I was mentioning that our reward
function now depends on this goal it's
not just our action and our observation
there's this additional bit of
information that's going to tell us okay
you could be in this location but it's
conditioned on whether or not you know
Glenn told you to go over to the corner
and grab him a bagel or if he told you
just go over there sit in the corner and
don't make any noise and your reward
function will be different
sorry
so when we're doing the some of the
simpler versions of goal conditioned RL
or you've got a goal and this is the
part when we're not doing images let's
just say you've got a robot it looks
just like me and I wanted to just go
into a particular pose at a particular
time and I can just specify that state
as the goal and now I can just make my
reward function look exactly like this
pose please do that thing
and for the moment this works really
well for goal conditioned RL but when we
get into images we really don't have
access to the State anymore and the goal
is also an image which isn't really a
complete way to determine what the state
is either
so it's very difficult to be able to use
this type of distance as a reward
function here without any additional
information
so the problem is really now that we
have observations distances inside of
the space of pixels don't really make
sense you know I can kind of show you an
image of a couple of things
but if you're just Computing things
inside of pixels it can get kind of
weird and how we're actually talking
about the task
so let's talk about like what we like
this issue that I mean where it's like
just using pixels is not a very good
idea
so you can have you know the image is
already a huge number of parameters and
you can't have small or large changes
yeah
so three images
okay so if you have like a 3D image or a
voxelization of your whole world it
solves one
I guess problem where you're still here
inside of like you got all of your state
information here but you still have an
extremely high dimensional piece of
State information
and the thing is there's a lot of things
about the world and they the way they
might change that are going to be
unrelated to the reward function
so I'll go like still with this example
here where the change in the pixels or
even like the voxels in this case might
not be really meaningful for the task
and we're trying to mostly use this for
the reward function right now
so one example for this is you can just
think about the background noise so like
in this image here we don't really care
about the fact that there's a green
sheet over the background of this it's
mostly so that you can't see all the
students in the background and that we
know that if things change in the
background it messes up our computer
vision pipeline
so in this case like even if some of the
voxels change they're not actually
related to the reward function or voxels
or pixels
and this I can give this example too so
if I take you know this Puck and the
idea was for the robot to move the puck
if the puck changes color does that
really change anything about what I'm
asking the robot to do
not really so I wouldn't so that means
in the distances that we really want to
compute we really don't want them to
change at all the color of the puck
changes it's still the same distance if
you move the puck in this case and it's
like it's more of an object uh Centric
idea that we really want to describe the
environment in
so this will help in the representation
quite a bit and ideally make your state
space your true task related State space
much smaller
yes
yeah so it doesn't know that quite well
so the question is yeah is there a
reward function specifically for this
type of goal so I mentioned it vaguely
here just that at least the reward
function is going to depend on this goal
and we're trying to find a nice way to
be able to determine the distances now
for this function before we could just
you don't want to just literally take
the difference between the pixels in one
image or the other because you're going
to get probably basically you're going
to not be telling the robot in this case
in more detail exactly what you want
you'll tell it vaguely maybe something
related to what you want but in my
somewhat painful experience it'll often
explore a bunch of stuff that's
unrelated to what you really want and
then you'll want to do more stuff like
this so that the only option for it to
do is what you're really asking it for
great oh my okay oh perfect so I'll just
maybe skip to this slide that rendered
properly so then one way to be able to
train a representation that's useful for
this space is you can use a variational
autoencoder
so the idea one of the ideas behind like
using a variational autoencoder is you
can take some representation
in this case images it might have more
information than what you need
and if we think more specifically about
the example for we're just training like
an mnist model it means you're taking in
an image that I think is like 27 by 27
but your data set actually only
represents 10 bits the numbers between 0
and 9 which means that this
representation here for Zed if you do a
really good job should basically just
capture the representation for the
numbers zero through nine that's what's
going to describe your state I'd much
rather condition my policy on the number
zero through nine then all of the pixels
that's I think somewhere in the hundreds
or near thousands for the whole number
for the picture and then you can
condition you know the model a little
bit better and it's like I don't know
make the board read the number three and
the robot can go draw that on the board
something like that
so this means in this space we should
have a much better representation that
we can use to compute distances even if
we've got voxel data too you can use
this as well it'll probably take longer
to train
um of course but then just like use this
overall model as one way to start to be
able to get these distance models
and
what you can use from this after then is
after you train this just take the
encoder part here that ends up producing
these Z's from the variational model and
now you can take your goal image and the
image your robot sees and just compare
the distance inside the latent space
between these two
and this
in practice works pretty well with the
one asterisk or caveat
that it might take a little while to you
know
tune your vae such that you do get a
good representation in this latent space
oftentimes a lot of the machine learning
models tend to focus on how good the
Reconstruction is which is a bit
unfortunate because my life always tends
to revolve around is how good is your
latent space this is Ed Vector you're
truly trained and often we don't
actually have supervised information
about telling me whether or not that
thing's good or not so this is my
partly been a pain point in my research
for a while but I've gotten pretty good
at training models that I've got
accurate enough
latent representation to be useful
okay so you can use that model
there's still a couple of like weird
catches yes go ahead
um yeah if you know that beforehand so
the question is you know do we if you
know something that there's going to be
some invariances in the data set you
should go about introducing those most
likely into like this latent space
there's a lot of good recent work that
does like hierarchical variational
autoencoders they tend to encode these
invariances in a good and slightly more
flexible way so I would start with those
as a way to introduce some of these
because oftentimes these invariances are
a bit compositional as well
so it's a good way way to go by like
ordering them so look at some of those
models they also produce fantastic
images and you can introduce them
structure pretty well
great
um all right
so there's still kind of one
bit of a problem with using part of this
model is also that we wanted to be able
to give the model goals
and in some cases
one of the nice things you can do
actually so if you were to like train a
model on a bunch of images of a robot
moving around in this room now you can
also use the second decoder part of the
ve to generate images of places in the
room that you can now you tell the robot
to go to so you can automate the whole
goal decision process during training as
well and this almost works well it works
really well but in real life it has at
least one interesting Corner case
darn so in this case what's going to end
up happening is there's two different
models and what was trained
is a different version of this that's
called
oh well
so there's okay I won't touch anything
it's finally rendering properly
so the problem with basically it is
taking from some like any distribution
and saying that we want to be able to
train a model and now using it to
generate goals for the agent is that
sometimes the configuration for the
agent might not match exactly what was
in that data set from before
so I'll give one example which is a real
common one so like if you were going to
train the robot that's going to be able
to cook a meal
and the problem is now you're going to
train this robot over cooking any meal
in the world but you're only going to
set out the actual like ingredients to
cook I don't know pizza or something
like that and now you're going to sample
a goal for it to perform and it's going
to sample a goal for I don't know making
japchae that just happened to be what I
cooked last week so in this case like
the environment is not even configured
this is in some way an invalid goal to
give the agent right now
so then a better way to be able to
generate these goals to give the agent
to learn from is at least condition it
on like
really in this case the first image of
the episode it's like give it a little
image of what it has in front of it and
then it can at least produce a set of
possible you know recipe goals that use
the ingredients that are set out for it
and this is what is done in this work we
basically just take the vae condition it
on this first image from the actual
environment so you can see like we put
one of these blocks in front of it then
we generate a goal location and it'll
generate a bunch of different locations
for these objects instead and we can
train it that way and this is helpful
because we can't just you know put every
single item here in a bin and have the
robot move all of them it's better if it
has more contextual information about
what to generate and what it can
actually interact with in its goals
yeah that makes sense
great
uh
Okay so
so we use a bit of an information
bottleneck you can look into this as
well to help make sure that the right
information stays inside of the latent
distribution for goal generation and the
latent distribution for like ignoring
the rest of what's in the trajectory
feel free to look into those details
later
oh and so a short practical note on
using these models which I'll go through
a bit quick
but really and I mentioned a bit already
what we actually feed to the policy in
most of these cases is the encoded value
from the vae encoder so instead of
having your policy also now learn a
whole new thing in image space you might
as well reuse your encoder from your vae
saves you a lot of time works really
well
okay
however
okay so I've unfortunately I convinced
you all that images are a great
representation to use for telling robots
what to do things
one of the really weird issues with
using images is they tend to really over
specify things
so maybe I'll zoom in a bit here so if
this was you know someone's room not
mine I swear mine is much more clean
than that somewhat often and you give it
this goal here all right cool make the
room clean
so there's this really weird Corner case
literally in this image that you're not
sure if you told this robot this thing
but there's a window here in the back of
the room
did you also just tell the robot to try
and like basically reverse time in the
universe set the rest of the world back
to this configuration that it was
outside in that window
we did that's what we said when we
trained the representation we gave it
this image it's not what we meant
hopefully
um and a robot probably have a really
hard time doing that but this means
images are good for some things but in
many cases that one of the challenges
with gold condition RL is we really over
constrain the problem to tell it to do
things we never really meant for it to
do
and so we want to avoid some of these
challenges in different ways
so one and we also wanted to generalize
better to novel goals so I given this
example like this only works if I also
have an example of my room clean at some
point
I would also like I'm sure we would all
like a machine Learning System where I
don't even have to provide an image of
my room being clean ever I can just say
cool go clean my room whatever that
means I should figure out and understand
the concepts for that and now I can
hopefully just benefit from other people
that clean the room at some point and
train a robot for that and I don't have
to provide this image
so this is where great there are some
advantages we can condition now instead
on text instead of on images and this is
becoming a really useful concept lately
for robotics the fact that we have
really large language models they
capture a pretty good representation of
what is meant by the text so that we can
use these
models in place of particular
representations for goals the one caveat
though is it does get more complex to
specify rewards now now what does it
mean when it actually gets you a snack
popular it cleans the room so mostly
we've had to collect a bit more data and
actually have people around to say okay
you actually achieved the sentence that
I specified for you so you have to have
some people label this data so we're
making a bit of a trade-off here though
to have this more flexible
representation it means we need other
type of data for the reward function
so then why does this work so I
mentioned it a bit like these large
language models they're trained over
these huge collections of data for text
so they have a pretty good
representation
and now instead of over specifying the
task for better or worse it's under
specifying the task and maybe who knows
people might ask you to clean your room
or you've got roommates and you say like
please go clean this thing everyone in
the room here probably has a slightly
different level for what they consider a
room being clean
so there's a bit of issues with saying
you know having an under specified task
now means that essentially you've also
possibly made it easier to do maybe a
little too easy to make it consider that
we've solved these tasks
so that's a slightly like different
problem where it's good that we're
getting these good representations
there's a little less Clarity on whether
or not it's as actually solved the task
we specified it to do and now we're just
collecting more data from humans and
we've got this difference in opinion
about what a clean room means
okay and there's also this second part
which is becoming more of a thing now
when we apply these when we actually
want them to before perform things in
the world
these large text models don't have
what's called grounding which means that
you know there might be the concept that
there's a cup inside of a language model
but what does it literally mean to bring
someone a cup there's like a physical
interaction there and in some ways if
you don't have a lot of connection
between the grounding and some
something else like a cup you might get
really weird things so a couple of you I
mean actually a bunch of you have
different kinds of cups in front of you
so what if the like robot mistakes a
particular object for not really being a
cop how do you define a cup it's kind of
like a vessel that hopefully holds
liquid kind of well
so you run into these you can have
disconnected Parts between what is the
actual physical thing and what the
grounding means in the representation
but for now it's still good to at least
have these symbols to specify them as
goals the agent can hopefully go out and
learn how to interact with these things
and you can give it you know like a one
or a zero depending on whether or not
achieved getting you a cup or cleaning
your room
and the part that's kind of the more
recent research right now is to figure
out how to integrate language models and
these image based models together
because if you tell it to go get a cup
maybe you can at least give it a picture
of the cup or something as well but also
the robot needs feedback on how well
it's doing when it goes to interact with
things if you just give it a goal it
also needs some other information to go
and figure out in the world to
understand how far it is away from that
text goal so it needs more visual
information
so that's why there's this great work
that came out really recently called
perceiver actor where it's doing this
combination so there is a text part for
the goal
there's also a voxel decoder in this
case to try to describe what the entire
scene is
and from here now that we've got this
good combination the robot can both act
understanding what the goal is inside of
the entire same network model and can
make connections basically to what's
being used inside of this visual
representation
it's some really neat work where even
you can look at it like you can give the
model a goal and it'll show you like the
affordance inside of the voxels on where
you know where does this sentence likely
mean that you want to interact with
these objects in the world so it's
matching now this better grounding
between the sentence structure and what
exists in the world and
predicting most likely the robot should
interact with these objects because
they're related to the grounding for
that particular text so this has been
some recent great work that can go in
that area you can look for that too
and then so that can work for solving
some of this grounding a multimodal
issue
so now I'm going to transition a bit
more a little quickly and kind of the
next problem that has a lot more to do
with how to get this to work in the real
world when we really don't have enough
data
so we can collect data across a number
of tasks and use this
so one of the things that these large
language models have also taught us is
the great abund like usefulness of
having a lot of data and then the
robotics kind of group is at least not
necessarily struggling with this but
it's a lot more expensive to collect an
equal amount of data on real robot
Hardware
but still one of the ways to get through
this is Google had some recent work
called the robotics Transformer or if
you can train this a robot model across
a bunch of different tasks you'll also
start to get better generalization this
is also linked to some other text models
but it's showing that this Paradigm that
if we keep at least collecting more
diverse data more tasks you can get a
better model of generalized to other
tasks
so this is a large kind of area of
research it's working well for robotics
we just need to find more and more
clever ways to collect data that's
diverse and it's still pretty cheap to
collect the data
okay so a real question is okay if it
still works for robotics where are we
going to get this data from
okay so one version of this is what I'm
going to call recycling
and it's an area where we maybe we can
train a model that essentially can
generalize across a bunch of different
robots
so it seems to be a bit missing here but
there are actually already is a lot of
robots out in the world you know there's
a couple of 10 million different
self-driving cars out there there's
actually a couple of million different
drones there's about five million
different robot arms in operation right
now doing stuff in different
manufacturing plants a lot of people
have roombas so there's actually a lot
of data collection going on out there
all across a bunch of different robots
though which is part of the challenge
but to start with can we even train a
model that can make use of all of this
data such that you know it's kind of the
idea of where
you can think of the concept where if I
were to train a robot you know just this
robot arm to learn how to you know pour
a cup of tea and train a different robot
that can learn how to walk across the
room we should be able to combine the
policy that's just pouring tea with the
walking robot so it can walk over to the
corner and pour some tea there isn't
really a large difference between these
two I should be able to combine them
kind of like the same way you'd make a
software API when you're trying to
figure out how to combine the different
functions you partly just need to figure
out how to make sure you can learn a
good API between all these different
robots
so this is nice for two reasons you can
hopefully get generalization across
robots and it should increase the data
you have now access to for robotics
applications at least by an order of
magnitude and then you can spend your
evenings like me trying to talk to
robotics companies to give you some
access to the robot data and then you
can start to train larger models as well
okay so then one recent example of this
that's part of some of the research I've
done is a method called antimorph so in
this case the idea is to do this quite
literally and if you're familiar with
robotics or you've done some RL
simulations in mojoku there's always
this really annoying file in the
background you can ignore called the
urdf file it describes more or less the
at least kind of dynamics of the actual
robot and they're incredibly difficult
and irritating to create and very
difficult to get to be right so that
your robot does what you want and
doesn't explode inside of the simulation
so you could go about training a model
that would you know give me an image of
the robot produce like the urdf file and
then you can train a model that can do
that
um long story short I'm way too lazy to
do that I'd like much easier more
automated systems
so in this case basically we trained a
Transformer model here where we can feed
in the state tokens beforehand and now
if we train it over about 50 different
robots and we just tokenize all of its
state variables it can learn to infer
what the morphology is after we train
over a number of different robots in
this case
and then from this we also start to get
a lot of generalization so here we've
got a model that can also like take
extra data from additional robots
but it also helps even increase the
performance of the actual model so if
we're thinking of the problem of okay we
want to train a policy that can control
50 different robots and the sample
efficiency of that problem now if we can
train a model more implicitly that can
understand now the Dynamics between all
the robots because in the real world our
physics doesn't really change Let's
ignore Quantum stuff in this room if you
don't mind
such that you know when you start to
combine different robots they still all
have really the same fundamental
dynamics that they're going to condition
their model on it's just trying to infer
how you've wired this robot together
so we get a lot of performance
improvements I think yeah where the
orange line here
in terms of being able to train things
faster
I believe no so are ours is the Blue
Line my mistake
so in this case we get a lot of sample
efficiency even during training just
because we're gaining some of that
shared Knowledge from all the other
robots that we're training this across
so is this this is that recycling idea
now I'm working on making sure this
works in more of an offline RL case
okay
yes
yes so so this is
I'm not exactly sure what you meant by
like the computation being cached but
this is definitely a version of doing
the contextual part I'm just also trying
to make the whole like policy model
infer the context implicitly by itself
internally to the model so I don't even
need to specify it now
I'm just going to give it the data that
it should need to be able to infer what
the context is
yeah happy to thank you
okay so yeah I'll go
you know we got the last part here as
well to get into this so the problem is
you know reinforcement learning can be
very often talked about it being very
data hungry and I'm gonna at least we
wanna still be able and reinforce anal
learning to get a lot of the great
advantages that we get in supervised
learning which is mostly you know we can
train from some fixed data set and
everything converges and is nice and
stable which hasn't been true for like
deep reinforcement learning in
particular for a very long time
okay and I wanted to say this is not
this part of the talk has nothing to do
with exploration it's really just about
if you have a fixed chunk of data can
you extract information as well as
basically people can or even better you
know because I like to set the bar High
so I like to look at this if anyone
remembers you know lacon's cake where he
was complaining that RL really only gets
a really small signal at the top of this
so this is really asking
between these two different questions is
what I want to talk about is RL really
data hungry or sample inefficient or is
it really just data wasteful in the fact
that we haven't figured out a good way
yet for it to be able to like digest and
gather every single useful bit out of
every data point that it does collect
so we want to figure out how can we make
it absorb and make use of this data
better
so supervised learning is good at this
and at least say for now like I wish
deep RL could overfit that would be a
nice property but instead of just
diverges and explodes with except with a
few exceptions I'll talk about now
so the problem is though like for on
policy learning you might get to use
your data points like maybe 10 times
before you get too off policy and now
your important sampling ratio just says
no and it starts to diverge
um off policy methods you know can start
to like theoretically work in this area
but it's because they're supposed to be
able to learn with possibly from data
from other policies but often they tend
to diverge a lot more as soon as we
start to use data that's more off policy
even for these models
so then we want to figure out how can we
get the most from basically every single
example of data that we collect so I'm
going to look at this from the point of
view of experience a replay
which is really you know kind of a
simple idea you probably talked about
hopefully earlier in this week or if
you've collected some batch of data
already and you add it to your data set
you want to replay this and your memory
so you just keep around some buffer they
just want to be able to sample this data
from this batch and be able to train
your policy this way
and then our goal here really is if we
want to talk about it algorithmically is
we want to be able to make this K you
know as large as possible can we just do
experienced memory and replay it over
and over and over and we still don't
diverge and we still get a very good
policy this would be like I'd like to be
able to have overfitting work properly
for RL and I'll worry about the other
issues but we can't even get this far
against
okay
so so we have basically these different
problems we're on policy there's a bunch
of algorithms but you can only use data
that's currently from the policy used to
generate it
model based based methods can be good
because they're often based on this
supervised learning Paradigm but they
have some other challenges for RL which
I'll talk about in a second and off
policy methods should be able to work
they kind of are trained from a version
of supervised learning with little
asterisks where there's some
bootstrapping in there and your Q
function you can learn but it's also
conditioned on a policy for your cue
function so it makes your life a little
more challenging
so I'm going to go right into this
what's called offline or batch
reinforcement learning depending on
which side of this country you're from
uh Harley's continent so model based RL
can work and it doesn't often like it
shouldn't diverge the problem is it's
challenging to make it planned for
really long Horizons and if you there's
also a another kind of different
theoretical challenge where there isn't
a very good like monotonic Improvement
theory for re model based reinforcement
learning so if your model becomes more
accurate it doesn't imply that you're
going to get better rewards which is not
a good property for the way we want to
be able to train models
so instead what about doing Q learning
so functions should be able to learn
stuff from other policies
the problem right now or at least has
been recently is that these would often
still diverge if you don't if you're
using off policy data in some way they
tend to diverge for different reasons
so a lot of this is related to a concept
called The Deadly Triad which was
introduced by a colleague
uh van assaults which basically says
that we combine for deep learning
bootstrapping function approximation
which is the Deep learning part and off
policy learning this just leads to
Divergence you can get away with
combining two of these and your life is
still okay and things don't diverge but
once you put in the third one now your
life is a real problem which is
unfortunate because the combination of
these three is usually when we get like
the largest best useful models
so then you can think about this
slightly new paradigm for offline
reinforcement learning where before we
would just like train a model online and
collect some data it learns from that
data now we're going to do this process
entirely offline you're going to train
an agent over some bit of data you've
collected already hopefully there's some
good stuff in there and then apply this
agent in the real world and our goal is
as we all want to be able to like train
this agent to be the best it can be even
from this offline data
the same way we do more stuff for
supervised learning like learn to
predict the best stuff from there so
then how can we get this to work
so this causes Divergence and let's look
at why
it's because one way to look at this is
that there's some distribution problems
and that there's basically a mismatch so
something at some point gave you this
data set that has all of this data
hopefully some of it's good the problem
is is you never have access to the
policy that was used to collect that
data
and where this starts to become an issue
is now you're going to construct a q
function and a q function gives you Q
values depending on some assumption for
a policy and now if you never have
access to the policy that used to
collect the data you're going to have to
make some other assumption that actually
it's going to act According to some
policy that was never really used to
collect data in the real world
and this is going to cause at least a
couple of different problems one is that
you know you're going to have a model
that's going to think it's going to do
great but because of this distribution
mismatch it's going to actually do
really terrible in the world because
it's still thinking that you know when
it takes actions and makes mistakes it's
going to follow this distribution but
actually it has its whole own policy
that's never really collected data
has a lot of different problems so this
has a lot to do with overconfidence in
the model
and a lot of this is related to support
you know where is our support in this
case
so if we look at we actually have data
for this small section at some State we
got some action data this is what's in
the data sets and we want to be able to
keep our models to say like it should
only really feel confident in itself
inside of the area that it has data you
know we're all scientists here we
shouldn't be coming up with a giant
Grand conjectures about stuff we have no
experience with and no idea for we don't
want our agents to do that either
so then what was done in some recent
work by Avril Kumar who's a colleague of
mine is let's be conservative
in this case let's introduce a
regularization term basically here that
if we're going to try and predict for Q
values for actions that aren't in our
support we should just basically squash
Q values that are outside of what we
actually have data for
so in this case you're basically saying
just be conservative
and this can work really well it's a
nice you know version of a method now to
be able to add on some small constraints
not too difficult to work with there's
an extra hyper parameter or two and now
we can at least make sure that the Q
values that we train these functions can
still work and they shouldn't be you
know over assuming or getting
overconfident in areas that has no data
which can happen again because we're
using function approximation so anything
outside of our support all bets are off
your Q function can predict pretty much
anything it wants out there and that's
not what we want to happen
so I know that was a bit quick so is
there any questions about the
I guess this objective so far
yes
that's the goal of this objective
so that means that there is an action
that is very good outside
correct it won't have any data for that
so it's assuming right now that for
actions outside of its data it doesn't
have knowledge and that it's going to
make a bit of this assumption that they
should probably have lower Q value
you can still go collect online data
later but it's without any more data
this is the Assumption it's going to
make
yeah so sorry that question was
um I think I mostly explained that if
it's going to assume some of the things
about what's only inside of the data set
okay and then for the last part
um so there's also a slightly different
way to look at this problem so you can
add a constraint here and this will be
good it'll help keep everything inside
of this particular distribution oh do
you have a question please go ahead
sorry so how does this relate to
distributional or at all ah okay so
they're they're not quite the same so
distributional RL is also trying to
figure out okay really our world is not
so there's a problem really with
assuming that we do Point estimates for
most of our Q functions when really
there's a lot of stochasticity in most
of our outcomes and we lose all of that
information in normal Q learning and
when we do distributional RL we're
trying to bring back that information
that actually our outcomes are not
perfectly deterministic
and that it helps to model this
additional information and we lose a lot
when we just do Point estimates for
models and then so in this case is
different where it's we're just trying
to estimate you can combine this sorry
this is still a point estimate then
um this is still just a point estimate
so you could add distributional RL on
top of this if you wanted to
sure thank you
great and then and then so there's a one
other way you can also look at this
problem so instead of adding like this
conservative constraint to squash the
values of things that are outside of the
data set
you can use sorry a type of behavior
cloning so just train a model you've got
a data set that goes from states to
actions use this data set you can train
a simple model that'll tell you what's
the probability of this action in this
state according to your data set
and then you can just change your ARG
Max and your Bellman back up a little
bit where instead of doing the max
overall actions which gives your
overconfidence instead use the
probability from this model that's from
your data set so really only select
things when you're doing this assumption
from things that were likely according
to your data set it's a very similar
idea this can also work very well
and so that I'm doing some more work
inside of this area now one of the
challenges with this is most actually
like deep learning models they're Point
estimates they don't capture multiple
modes very well
so if you use a better model maybe like
a diffusion prior a GMM something
that'll represent the distribution of
actions better you end up being able to
apply this model better and getting
better learning over time and a better
high quality policy
okay
so then the last thing I'll touch on is
so these were like a very RL focused aim
at what the problem is for getting
overconfidence but remember we can still
look at it from the deadly Triads so
function approximation was still one of
the issues so what if our function
approximator just wasn't so terribly
behaved we should be able to get a
better model and not have so much
Divergence issues
so we can look at this from the point of
view of having issues there and having
early overfitting
so some of my colleagues at Mila have
been talking about this research lately
that's been really great related to the
Primacy bias and avoiding overfitting
and the idea is is there's a lot of
complex Network dynamics that go on when
you're training a policy especially for
RL because you're essentially getting
new data all the time and your
distribution changes is aren't the
issues that you have in supervised
learning
so if we want to be able to avoid kind
of this issue where your network will
overfit data really early on and then
you can develop really kind of poor
behavior in the Dynamics of your network
the idea is to basically reset or prime
the network and this for the moment is
introducing some inch some more like
useful Behavior inside of the network
Dynamics
that allows these models to generalize
better probably even local areas it's
most likely introducing some better ways
a bit more for extra extrapolation but
more likely better interpolation between
the data that you already have
so in this case if you just take like a
version of Sac and you reset just like
the last layer of the network just by
adding a little bit of noise to it it's
more difficult for that Network to now
overfit the data and become really
overall confident really early on
so now if we look at it this way you can
use these resets to help condition your
model better just from the whole network
function approximation area don't even
need to get into the problems about by
this doesn't make sense for RL
and this still gets the idea where
they're also examining What's called the
replay ratio this is that same version
where we want K to go up to Infinity so
that we can basically make as many
passes as possible over the data that
the agent collects so this has been
really helpful for being able to
increase that replay ratio even for
online data and that's why the sac model
can learn faster because it's actually
Gathering the bits from its experience
like as best it can or at least better
than other algorithms
oh sorry
and then yeah and there's some there's a
follow-up to a couple more of these
Primacy bias papers where they're
finding much better ways to be able to
do this resetting especially when
getting into much larger neural network
models which would more common those
cause more Divergence than reinforcement
learning as well
okay and if you want this I posted my
slides on the slack Channel you can look
at some of the details there and some
details on the algorithms okay
that's okay thank you for listening and
then that's everything I talked for
today thank you